[Music]
anyone who's anyone in the world of
social media has to visit this little
street in the twelfth effandi samal of
paris if ever they find themselves in
the French capital there are already
more than 36 thousand photos with the
hashtag hug them you on Instagram Kelly
and Tanya live an hour away from Paris
they're hoping to pimp up their
Instagram feed it's so colorful so we're
taking colour pictures it's prettier the
pictures come out nicer is it pretty
where you're from no not at all fed yeah
there are just buildings it's not pretty
like Paris but the local residents are
sick of people taking pictures of their
homes day in day out people just turn up
and starts snapping away so they've
taken to hiding inside
the residents used to take their tables
to eat outside but not now and I
understand why everyone's here because
of Instagram not to take a picture of
the street but because it's become
fashionable to go to room most of the
locals refused to talk about the subject
in front of the camera they say that
each report just makes things worse
journalists are no longer welcome here
it's annoying we're sick of it why is he
filming me enough already I'll break
your damn camera rappers and dancers
make videos here there are drunken stag
parties a local residents Association
has put up a sign banning photos and
videos but it's all in vain so long as
the police don't interfere tourists just
keep coming
Daniel amantha this photo was uploaded
eight minutes ago this one ten minutes
ago another twenty five minutes ago the
rule of Instagram is about imitating if
something goes viral people want to do
the same thing they want to have as many
followers as possible a man do from
Madeira doesn't need a guidebook all the
information is online I saw a lot of
like famous posting here like an
Instagram spot it follows some some some
travelers around the world you may say
influencers I think and I saw I saw a
lot of pictures in here so I was curious
and I went to see the locals have
demanded barriers that the entrances at
either end of the road they would like
to close them at least at the weekend no
barriers yet but some rest fight might
ironically come from the world of
advertising the holcombe you has become
a mainstream money-making phenomenon
which could put the Instagram as off
here's an account with pictures of Rue
creme you if you click on the dress you
see the brand is maja outfits and if you
click again you go to their account and
see their selling clothes creme you is
already becoming less fashionable
because everyone knows it
so people are already looking for the
next place so the locals might be able
to come out of their home soon and get
out their tables again the instagramers
meanwhile will surely have invaded
another quiet idyllic street